[Music]
but hi everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout if we haven't met before
I'm Rachel Dempsey I'm the host of our
hangout here and I lead customer
marketing at posit this is our open
space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear about what's going on in
the world of data across different
Industries so we're here every Thursday
at the same time same place so if you
are watching this on YouTube at some
point in the future and you want to join
us live there'll be a link in the
details below where you can add it to
your
calendar at the Hangouts we're all
dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everybody so we love to
hear from everyone no matter your years
of experience your titles your industry
or the languages that you work in too
it's totally okay to just listen and
here as well I know sometimes people
will be out for a walk maybe you're on
your lunch break or it's later in your
day and there's always three ways though
that you could jump in and ask questions
or provide your own perspective so one
you could jump in by raising your hand
here on zoom and I'll be on the lookout
two you can put questions into the zoom
chat and if it's something you wanted me
to read instead just put a little star
next to it
um and then three we also have a slid
link which I'm sure Curtis or someone
from the team will share in just a
second here where you can ask questions
anonymously
too but with all that thank you for
spending your Thursday with us I'm so
excited to introduce my colleague and
co-host for today Julia Sil Julia is a
software engineer here at posit Julie
I'd love to have you introduce yourself
and share a little bit about your role
maybe something you like to do outside
of work too great I yeah hello everyone
I'm so glad to be here my name is Julia
and I have worked at um pit
for going on four years now and um when
I was first hired to and so I work on
one of the open source teams um who
focuses on open source software and um
mostly are um I when I first came to
then our studio
I was on the Tidy models team and I was
on the Tidy models team for two and a
halfish years something like that and it
was a really exciting time to work on
the Tidy models team because it was just
kind of getting to a point where it
really was mature enough to be used for
people's real um machine learning and
modeling um workflow so that was really
exciting um from when I was hired
originally one of the things that was
kind of on the table for like what like
something I would work with would be to
work on the really um applied and
practical problems of um of of of
deployment of what like what you need to
do with a model after you have trained
it and so uh I after being at on the
Tidy models team for about a year I kind
of started digging into that and then
maybe
about a year after that I transitioned
to really working on that
um fullish
like um like uh like most of my emphasis
going to those kinds of deployment kinds
of things so if you've the and we also
hired someone to from the beginning the
plan was that of that was always to make
that something that worked for R and
python because the the technologies that
people use to deploy models are really
not very specific to what language you
use to train them in and so we really
saw this as an opportunity to help
people have choices and um have a
unified Approach at the end so um uh so
that the the mlops kind of project is
one that is um bilingual that is r and
python so we use um we do just that do
both of that so if you have ever um used
something like um pins um me and my team
work on that for r& python um the
particular package that is focused on
like model deployment is vver and then
there are other kind of like hand full
of things that that are a little lower
level that are kind of behind some of
these things that we um that we take
responsibility for and maintain so I um
you know like most of the people who
work on open source software I do a mix
of writing actual code and then writing
documentation and making material so
that people can know how to use our
tools so that's a little bit about um me
and what I do here and the kind of
things that I focus on awesome and what
about something you like to do outside
of work ah yes yes um so I um I would
say that my um I I don't have something
like really exciting for this list it's
like um reading books watching TV shows
doing things with my family like nothing
really unusual or out of the ordinary I
um I uh I am like I almost pains me to
admit this but like since the um sort of
disintegration of Twitter um I have read
twice as many books this year as I did
last
year that's great yeah it's good but I
always maintained like I was like oh no
it doesn't affect me it's not taking up
that much of my time but I literally
have read twice as many books this year
as I did last year and I read a couple
just now that were very sort of spooky h
Halloween appropriate um one is called
one is like a really sort of warm sweet
ghost romance it's called the dead
Romantics lovely and then one is like a
sort of um uh like a kind of gothy
sci-fi kind of thing it's called Gideon
the 9th and it was also a delight
although more
gory not not too much I can't handle a
lot but like but like a little more grim
love that we can bring a little like
Halloween theme into this week yeah it's
fantastic I saw um moris had a great
call out to your YouTube channel as well
and I I thought it might be nice to just
ask a little bit about that first like
what led you to start creating some of
those videos and can you tell us a
little bit about them sure sure so I
um I think I started at first as like an
experiment so I
I've done blogging for a long time and
and like my initial sort of like
motivation for blogging was that I was
actually transitioning into data science
as a career this was this is maybe like
10ish 8ish years ago and I um was trying
to make a career transition before my my
academic background is like physics and
astronomy and I've been doing um uh I
was in research for a long time then I
did worked like at an edtech startup and
like or a Ed Tech kind of company and I
was like transitioning into data science
and I thought okay I have this weird
kind of um background I don't like how
like how are people going to know that I
can do this job at all and so blogging
was part of me kind of trying to have
this idea of like a um a portfolio to be
able to for for my own sort of career
growth kind of thing but it really led
to so much that was good in my life and
career and when I came here to work at
the then our studio um uh tidy models
was really at a point where
um was really at a point
where uh like a like a thing to deal
with is like how do we show people how
to use this how do we um like how do we
demonstrate it so I did it kind of as an
experiment to be like is this something
that would be helpful to people I
honestly like it's interesting I like I
would always rather read something than
watch a video about like personally like
I'm like oh my gosh just let me read it
why is everything a video now I like I'm
like in my mid 40s so you know but but
at the same time there were times when I
would like watch videos and I was like
oh I didn't know you could do that or
like oh I never saw someone do that like
in the way they actually were writing
code or the way they use their IDE or
something like that and so I'm kind of
like I kind of see the benefits of both
video and for communication and teaching
and all that and um written written and
written is certainly my first choice and
so you'll notice like all my screencasts
like I pop up a quick blog post like I
don't put a ton of energy into it but I
always like they're all there's always a
place you can go to see it I also think
I also do that partly because I have had
people talk to me about the um uh the
accessibility issues around video for
communication and if you have something
that is text you know that's HTML like
on a website like that's much more
accessible to um uh to people who need
to use screen readers or you know like
have like so I always try to do both I
always try to do both but I was so at
the beginning I was like let's do an
experiment let's see and I think it
really helped people see tidy models as
something that was like oh I can try
that let me let me do that let me do
that and so that would be kind of what
went into the start of it and then um
certainly as I've moved depending on the
balance of my time in every given month
I don't always like my sort of goal is
to like do two a month but I don't
always hit two a
month I really like having both the
video and in blog format too because if
you get stuck in either one you go to
the other and kind of unblocks you yeah
but um I see Ben you had a question in
the zoom chat do you want to jump in
here yeah yeah hey Julie um curious
you've obviously been on long-term to
Value projects longer term so you're not
able to see The Benchmark is just really
high and I'm I have a couple that I'm
working on as well um for an internal
solution and it's hard to maintain the
excitement also to create that um that
vision for the end goal and also to vet
it out so I have like five different
questions built into this okay okay
let's see if I can remember them all
let's do them one at a time
so the idea is uh the main one is how do
you
maintain excitement and enthusiasm but
also maintain a clear scope over a long
term to Value Pride especially yeah yeah
yeah yeah so this
um um is a great question I think that I
think that the number one thing is to is
to you you know I I know you all have
seen these kind of pictures but like you
you can think about like waterfall
versus like MVP right and you've seen
those pictures of like making a bike or
something it's like what do you do make
first do you make a wheel and you're
like I made a wheel here it's ready and
then you make the seat ah here's a seat
or do you like is the first thing that
you make like a really simple
skateboardy thing that like someone can
use to get somewhere and then you you
change and change so I think I think it
is is so important to make to to build
in such a way that at any given point
there's something that you can show and
um I and say like here is the idea of
what it's going to be and and I'm going
to improve it this way and this way and
then improve it in ways and it is true
that sometimes this means um it can take
longer to get to the eventual thing like
the perfect bike kind of thing that you
have but the um um it is I think so
important for buying from stakeholders
and it's so important for people seeing
you as someone who ships and who um and
who gets things done and it provides
something useful that you get something
useful as early as possible even if it
is not the the eventual way you're going
to do it like I I think adopting that
kind of mindset it makes a huge
difference in how collaborative people
think you are and how responsive people
think you are like like your
organization how your um position with
an organization if you are if you can
break break things down you know if you
there there I mean there's tons of books
and blog posts about this I'm not saying
anything crazy or new but even for
something statistical you know like um
can I do can I give someone something
that is dead simple now and then can I
iterate iterate iterate right like if
you were talking about a machine
learning context it's like can I do
something that I almost even didn't have
to train or that doesn't use machine
learning right like as an initial kind
of like here it's going to look like
this it's going to be this API and right
now what's serving it is is something
like so dumb like so simple and then you
do a model that you can train in a you
know literally 10 minutes right and then
you you do that and then you you try to
improve it rather than to get to
something great um I think that that
does have to be balanced right with um
uh how
much um time you know just time it takes
to do projects right but I think within
the scope of whatever kind of project
you're doing if you can really think
about not trying to build it up in
pieces so that the individual pieces
like that they're not that they're as
useful as early as possible even if that
means you build it simpler um I so I
think that is is that is important and
that really
helps the teams I've been on in that um
in that like maintaining motivation
because if people are actually using
even the very early versions of what
you're doing um you get feedback on it
you learn about what you learn earlier
what people are actually looking for um
and uh that that kind
of like versus that sort of a very sort
of siloed feeling of like well I'm just
going to grind away
for a very long time on this big project
but instead of that feeling like what
about this what about this like getting
feedback and can I I think for teams I
have worked on has been very motivating
very motivating can I can I ask that
next oneel go for it yeah go for
it I love I love that explanation too
though
Julia so the the ideas that come about
obviously you're not limiting yourself
to just like two ideas that you've had
over the last or seven years so how do
you vet the ideas that you're coming up
with and that you're seeing with
yourself and also with your team to make
sure that they're they're valid and
they're worth creating a vision around
that's a great question so you're asking
if
um uh uh okay yeah so I am I am also a
pretty big fan of of like small
experiments you know like small
experiments and hypotheses and this is
is this is like related to the thing
that we were just talking about about um
um deciding like getting to
something uh show like demo level
getting to
something um you know there's these like
minimal viable project you know like
these are the kind of words getting to
something as early as possible like
literally sometimes time boxing
something to one afternoon one hour even
right like what can I get in one hour
and can I show this to someone and get
feedback on it and see what resonates
about it and what doesn't um I so that I
would think is like one of
the
biggest um sort of tools I've used to
evaluate ideas or evaluate hypotheses
like if we try um something is it is it
like um does it resonate does someone
want to see more does someone want to
have to change as they want to suggest
it or are people kind of like I don't
know I um like I I am I'm really biased
towards like ship early and experiment
and don't have and I does mean that like
you like for me it's like I have to have
an attitude of like holding these things
with a very light hand that I'm like I'm
not super invested in this or this like
um I I just want to know like like what
do you think what do you think like that
type of thing so um I on the on the
positive like example of this I that is
how V happened actually so um I think I
was like it's like mlops as a tool feels
so or as a field or idea feels like so
big a little hype driven and like what
like oh we can't like we say we as
posites like can we can we play in that
space is that reasonable for us there
whole startups that that's nothing what
they do and like I had a hypothesis I
was like I think I think the pieces are
here in open source and people are
already like kind of bailing why are
these things together them themselves if
they're not like buying into like a
startup producty kind of mlfs thing what
if we made like an open source thing
that really used uh components pieces
that are already there and so the
initial version that I like showed
someone was like I think we have most of
what we need and we just need to make
like the user experience nice for this
particular modelbased use case and so
that was um um you know like the initial
sort of I did actually my the initial
sort of thing I made was um was was
actually much more shiny like and ended
up being like Oh in terms of like uh
what it looked like like a server uh you
know like all this kind of thing and I
ended up I ended up there ended up being
a fairly big shift of like okay no no no
we're not going to do it that way we're
going to
um uh instead do like uh code generation
a fair amount of code generation behind
the scene kind of so it kind I kind of
shifted but there were things about the
initial version I showed people that
resonated they're like okay they want to
do X and then there were things about it
they were like I don't know like H
that's not making sense to me or like
that seems to complicated it like I
think I should be simpler and so there
were things that about it that helped me
iterate towards something um uh and then
we kind of like iterate iterate and like
keep going forward and like land on
something that hopefully fits pretty
pretty well so I think that I
um I
probably
lean Le less I would say on my
own opinions or taste I'm like I am sure
this is right and I tend to um I tend to
lean more on let me like show things to
people let me do even user interviews
you know like let me like uh uh use some
of those tools to um figure out how
things need to happen yeah I I see
there's a little conversation in the
chat happening about this too and we can
definitely jump on to other topics too
but I want to make sure while that
conversation's happening we dive in to
um George do you want to add your follow
on question
question yeah yeah um I guess I've had
the experience where people really don't
want to see those intermediate steps
that just want that final thing um
especially to your point about like you
know even even in cases where it's a
statistical um you know model or
something that you're needing to deliver
sometimes that delivering a simple thing
is is good enough I've had the
experience where it's just not and and I
think it's because of perception of like
stability or um you know maybe just the
the
culture and so I don't know if you ever
come across that but it's like it's
basically you have to sell the whole
thing or else it dies and I don't know
if you if you ever had that experience
and how you goome that yeah yeah yeah so
this this experience where um someone is
not doesn't view it as important to give
feedback on an intermediate thing or to
look at an intermediate thing or to it
start integrating something that is that
is less complete or less mature or less
finished um into maybe the system that
you're that you're going for um so if it
is something if it is really something
that you're like
I I need I need feedback on these
intermediate steps in order to get where
I need to go
um it it can be helpful
to um
explain why you know like explain why we
want
to
um build things in a with with an in an
iterative improvement you know if you're
if you're talking to a um software
engineer colleague they they probably
resonate with this idea right because
it's so common in software engine ing
this idea of like we do something small
then we improve it you know like we
don't do something we don't do something
huge and massive all all at once right
like we know that's more prone to errors
it's more prone to not getting where you
want to be all that so so you can so I
have had luck with software engineer
colleagues in explaining this is like
what you do but for data work you know
so I need you to um I I need to us to
take these steps so that we end up in a
better place in the long run um I think
that it would you know it may be
interesting George to um like if you're
having this kind of problem more with
say like a business stakeholder like
less with an engineer an engineering
kind of stakeholder in your day to work
and more like a business
stakeholder and I have had more
challenges and those situations and
trying to
um and and trying to get
uh get those kinds of um answers so so
sometimes I have been in a situation
where I just
share and um partly and as a like here's
where it is and the next steps are X
next week here's where it is next steps
are y if I do need feedback if I do need
like um I need something back the other
direction um
it can be more challenging with business
stakeholders uh to understand that but I
when I have had success with that kind
of overcoming that kind of obstacle it
has been through a fairly
specific request or like a fairly
specific like
um I have a you know I have a prototype
of um the statistical results it's not
it's in fin it's final version but I
need to ask you these questions about it
and if like either set a meeting or if
it's async like a question a question B
question C and then to like when I've
had success it's been it's been they
like I really clearly understand why I
need something it's like the goal is
this to get to the goal I need to know
which of these things to but that can be
a more because there's less of a culture
I think like in in with Engineers
there's more there's more of a norm and
expected culture around like we do
things iteratively to get a better
better result but I have had more it has
been more challenging there and then I
think connecting it to like what is the
goal and saying like this is what I need
has been how I have had success in that
but I have sometimes been a situation
where I just feel like am I just putting
this out into the void you
know it's an interesting thought to
think about how we get other people to
think iteratively as well
um but h i I see you had a question a
bit earlier about tidy models do you
want to jump in and I can read the
question and if you want to jump in and
add more context feel free but the
question was how are the state of Tidy
models adaptations are there enough
adopters or users to please the Tidy
models team's metric or Target are there
targets yeah that's a great question um
so I think that um
it
is uh so when I have
been while I've worked on open source
projects um adoption right like is a is
something that
we that like open source teams watch
that open source teams pay attention to
and decide you know like um well it's
like one piece of data we have to decide
how to invest and what to invest in like
if um you know if there are like two
things we can invest in or project we
invest in what how do we prioritize them
one of the things that goes into is um
is things like adoption it's not the
only thing because sometimes that's not
the only reason to um invest in
something um uh like I I talk about this
all the time all the time but you
probably are familiar with the idea of
like the data science hierarchy of needs
Monica ratti wrote about this like like
2017 or 16 or something and at the
bottom is like you're collecting data at
all and then one up is you're doing
you're doing analytics things like
dashboards one like a level up from that
is like
um uh is like like U like statistical
analysis like uh maybe things like a t
test or maybe something like a linear
model and up above that you're using
machine learning and at the top is like
like AI you know kind of thing and and
you can think about that also in terms
of like like where where does model
deployment go on that like it it's up
pretty high like people have to be using
um have to be having models they need to
have models that are deployed like like
it's up pretty high in that hierarchy of
needs so that so that affects adoption
numbers right like something like tidy
models is never going to have the
adoption numbers of something like shiny
because they're at kind of at like
different places in the data science
hierarchy of needs um so but at the same
time like if you're thinking about what
should we invest in you want to make
sure that when people look at tooling or
a language or um a company's products or
something that when people look at it
they can see that it can grow with them
they can see that like this is not a
tool that like maxes out or or if you do
decide to do that you need to do it very
carefully right like when people look at
this tool um they're going to understand
it scope is limited and they can't use
it Beyond X level you know of scale or
maturity or whatever so there's
different there's different reasons I
would say that in terms of
adoption um that um the the when we look
at like who wants to come to conf and
learn about something or like who um if
we look at like who like internally and
our customers like how often are people
asking about a tool or wanting like to
know more about how to do something like
we we um feel good about the investment
that um has been made in in tidy models
certainly certainly um when you think
about um like if you were to go right
now GitHub and like count up right like
how many people like how many things are
using tidy models versus something else
right which you know you might what
would you compare it to like would you
compare it to carrot would you compare
it to pyler you know like like probably
when you if you were to compare those
numers you'd be like oh there's more
projects that use carrot because carrots
been around for like 15 more years or
something like that or pyit learn many
more project for for reasons that we
understand but um I so I think that if
you ask the question like are is is is
posit happy about the investment that
has been made in tidy models um I think
it really fits a need like a need that
people have and so in in that sense has
been really happy about the um
investment awesome um Julia a question I
wanted to ask you is I see a lot of
things on LinkedIn that are like models
are rarely deployed or oh teams spend
all this time developing something and
it doesn't go anywhere like why does
that
happen I think some of the time that's
appropriate like that's normal and okay
um because um one thing that's different
about uh machine learning as a practice
compared to software engineering as a
practice is you can pretty much
always get you can pretty much always
build something like if you write out a
spec for something that's like we need
to build X and like as a software
engineer let's write out a spec let's um
do it like you pretty much always can do
that you know maybe it maybe it will
take longer than you think or more inv
investment than you think but actually
that's not true when it comes to machine
learning because until you start the
process you don't necessarily know that
you can predict the thing that you need
to predict from the stuff that you have
you you may you end up may end up not
having appropriate data you may end up
um uh it is not good enough like the
results you get are not good enough to
predict that you think that you want to
um so it uh so machine learning
as a practice is it's more iterative uh
it's more exploratory even you know I'm
not we're not even talking specifically
about like exploratory data analysis but
as a as a practice it is more
exploratory than say we're going to
build a feature we're going to build a
feature and it's it is um there you know
you can be less certain ahead of time
that the whatever model you're going
you're trying to do you can actually fit
especially within whatever is needed so
I think that it happens because that
that's a big reason why it happens is
that that is the nature of data science
nature of machine learning there's a
really great um paper um I'm gonna see
if I can find it real um quick that
talks about this
um that
um yes okay I found it it's called
operationalizing machine learning and
I'll put the the link here and it talks
about it talks about this in the context
of machine learning especially and
really just says this is this is why
like this is why it's because the nature
of um of this work so that's what big
reason I think another reason is that it
um often when people are like working on
machine learning projects in their org
they're bumping up against the maturity
of where they've been before where their
org has been before and so people
um uh don't have as much of the muscle
memory and the skills about how to do
these things how to deploy them so
that's I think so the big I think big
reason is like it is the nature of
machine learning as work the next piece
is that often when people are doing
these things it's new to their org or
newer um they're they're exercising new
skills and the other thing I think that
really contributes to this is um you all
you almost always are ending up
collaborating across functions so most
typically like you are needing you if
you are more statistical person you are
now needing to collaborate with someone
who's a more opsy person and people work
in different ways teams um don't sit
together team like like like people end
up with like oh that will never work you
know like that will never work because
of X and like what like what can both
sides do to actually make something work
if it needs to happen so I think those
are like the real reasons why this kind
of thing happens thank you I see Patrick
you had asked a question that I think
kind of like follows along to this
nicely if you want to jump in here
too thanks Rachel and Julia hi it's good
to see you uh yeah this is this is very
much what you were just talking about
and and sort of references back to the
the data science hierarchy of needs
piece too uh so I'm just wondering like
what advice would you give to a team or
an organization who's struggling to go
from okay we have a model and it fits
well enough and it's sort of doing what
we wanted to do uh to having a model in
production that we're using regularly
and that we that we depend on that it it
feels like a very big change to me uh
psychologically for the team or the
organization to to go from you know yes
we can do this to uh yes we we are
relying on this thing and is in
production it's important to us so so
what advice do you have for for people
who are struggling to make that step
yeah yeah so I think one thing is to
acknowledge to understand that you you
as a team or some part of the team is
going to need to um gain some new skills
is going to need to learn how to do some
new things and to try to make space and
understand that that that kind of that
kind of change is is coming and is
needed so this is um for example uh you
know you know like maybe it's important
for someone on your team to start in um
learn like kind of learning like what
does our org need if I we were to deploy
a model like what is going to work for
our org so this is is now working with
maybe people who are Dev opsy maybe
people who are I sit in it like like
what do so so what are the new skills we
need to um add uh so that's that's one
thing is to acknowledge that if you have
been very statistically focused and it's
time to deploy a model how can we make
space for some proportion of our team to
to gain some of those um some of those
skills I think also to not be afraid of
some of those tools and skills and to um
understand understand that like that's
how you um scale the impact of your work
so so for example like to learn um you
know about Docker right like to learn
about um um uh like like what like what
in your how do things work in your org
if your org has like a like a certain
Cloud platform that they that that you
all use like to start to to not so much
be like okay yes well we're the data
people that they we work in this
environment but to start to kind of push
again like to find how do I go how do I
then take that next step also I think
doing things in as small a way as
possible so like you can um if you're
going to deploy some kind of a model as
um like like as an API it's like it
doesn't have to the first time you do it
be the huge
scalable can go to Infinity kind of API
like you can first do a a um API at all
and then you show you you know like a
software engineer or Dev opsy kind of
cooworker like look look if we serve
this in this way then we you can get
predictions back in this way and then
have a discussion about like how can we
start to to scale that up so I think the
first thing is to think about um the
skills that people need someone needs to
gain a little bit the second thing is to
think about um infrastructure and like
like your the tools you use now how are
they different from the tools that are
me there like what can you learn about
your internal spe specifics and then
also going back to that like iterative
like do something as small as possible
to show and be like okay how can we make
take that take that next step got it
thank you very much Julie I appreciate
that and thank you for building all the
tools that uh make that stuff possible
and easier uh and yes uh fear of Docker
sounds like a great horror
movie I know I know I know I also um I
just shared in the chat too if it's
helpful for anyone especially with this
conversation right now yesterday Simon
couch from our team led a demo using
tidy models and posit team and so it's a
nice walk through as well I just put
that link in the chat that looks so
great I'm really excited Simon was able
to do that yeah it was really fun uh
there are a lot of people there too
which is great um an an anonymous
question that came in was if only or
what it say if only there was a good way
to share these data science endpoints do
you have any advice on deploying and
managing these kinds of outputs yeah so
I think that it is really important to
find the an easy way
to um do this in a
um like like be able to have an MVP to
be able to have a demo to and then then
you can work from there so if you for
those of you who are customers or having
like trying to make a argument around it
like that is exactly what connect does
like connect is a way that you as a data
scientist can can deploy
something with one function with one
button kind of click like it really it
really lets you have like a a like a
playground and then depending on the um
it really reduces the barrier to that
first kind of like ah I am serving an
API like here it is if you are if you
are in a situation where that's not
reasonable for your org um I think that
the um then then you are in a situation
where you need to like have a
conversation with your organization is
like well since we don't have a tool
that does this um then you are asking me
to gain some of that skill like are you
making space for that like like is that
what we're going to do because if it's
not like a product kind of thing like
connect that really is built for you as
a as like you are the one it is built
for right like you as a data scientist
to be able to deploy an API publish an
app all these kinds of things then
you're like okay then I need to be able
to make like then you need like the org
needs to
acknowledge that you're asking me to
gain some of those skills and so I think
so plumber has a pretty nice set of
documentation for like how to deploy
plumber apis and uh they have you know
Docker containers that are ready to go
they have I think um um droplets um like
like a way to like you can deploy it in
uh shoot I forget what's the what's the
place that has droplets I'm blanking um
the cloud
provider uh I can't remember digal
digital ocean that's right it that's
right so it's like okay are do you need
a deploy a plumber API here's how you
can just take it to digital ocean which
does have fairly um good documentation
ways to ways to get um ways to get
started so um the it is harder if you're
not able to kind of lean on a product
that's made for you you know like as a
person who uses python or R and wants to
deploy an API you then are in a
situation where your org is asking you
to do to do do it yourself maybe or to
talk to talk about it so the plumber you
know or or fast API you know like like
there's documentation there like how do
you actually get fast API from running
on your computer to running somewhere
else um there's a lot of ways to answer
that question and some of them are quite
easy and built for you as a data science
user Persona and some of them mean you
really do have to start going into those
more um opsy areas I will say if you are
a person that combines like statistical
knowhow with like opsy knowhow like
that's killer career-wise so so I mean
go for it if like you're interested and
and you have a little bit of the space
to start gaining those skills like that
that's fantastic like that that like
those are people who like that set of
skills combo of skills is like super
valuable in the market you know when you
hear about like oh data scientists you
know like ah I'm so annoyed it's like
data scientists never ship data
scientists have terrible software
engineering practices like the coding
practices so if you if you are someone
who's like no no I can do that I know
how to do that I can learn I can I have
learned X I'm in the process of learning
why like like the that's that's
wonderful for your career so that's like
a sort of look on the bright side kind
of like Silver Lining kind of situation
if you know like if you are if that is
true for
you thank you GNA jump over to some a
few questions from a bit earlier um Lisa
had asked well she's taking the dogs on
a walk so I will read it um wondering
how the team finds time to respond to
questions on posit community and other
message boards is that part of the job
I'm so thankful you and others from fet
Do It um absolutely I we consider it
part of our job so I think that um uh
and I Lisa's back feel to jump in and
say hi Lisa so I would say for the teams
I have been on we absolutely um have
considered it um part one one I'm just
gonna one one one second awesome thank
you so much um so absolutely absolutely
the teams I have been on considerate
part of our job I do think it depends on
the maturity of the project that you're
working on so for example um
um Hadley has told me like when he was
first working on GG plat 2 he answered
every stack Overflow question about GG
plate 2 or at least he looked at it he
looked at it he made sure that and and
because it's really valuable source of
feedback like it's a really valuable
source of like it's it is actually good
for you but now ggplot 2 is very mature
and there's many people who answer
questions on stack Overflow about ggplot
to and so Hadley doesn't do it anymore
so um I have set up like RSS feeds for
posit Community questions for stack
Overflow that come to like a place that
I check like I have it going to an RSS
feed reader and so I for for a for like
I literally every time there's a
question on stack Overflow that's tagged
tidy models I look at it I look at it
every single one of them and you know
sometimes someone has beat me to
answering it and that's fine unless they
answer it wrong you know and so that's
totally fine but I just want to make
sure anyone
who comes and is having a problem we
know what it is we know what it is it's
really interesting working on open
source software from the perspective of
like how do you decide what to do and
what the problems are because you know
lot lots of you I think probably work in
a situation where you have data right
that's why you're hired there's data
that exists and you use that data to
improve some product or to like change
something when you're working on open
source software just by the nature of it
we don't have data about usage we don't
have data about like what most common
errors are so you kind of have to find
proxies for that and I think things like
questions on posit Community questions
on stack Overflow certainly GitHub
issues like these are the proxies that
we have for what problems are people
having and so I think it is absolutely
yes part of the job of like um figuring
out what people's problems are and and
like I said this especially applies to
early maturity projects that um that
like that's that's it's incred it's in
fact incredibly valuable data that you
can use to um to decide what it is that
you need to do it definitely you have
have you have to have like a certain
mindset if you're going into this
because um people ask turns out people
ask the same question over and over no
but like the the fact is like either you
need to if someone's if you are finding
multiple people are asking the same
question over and over um you should fix
that you should fix that or better
document that or like make it easier for
people to like not have to ask that
question anymore but definitely
definitely if you're in you know that's
that part the job of like okay let me go
through here here here like all the
questions and feedback let me know let
me keep in mind that person is
frustrated that person is having a
problem um even if I think oh my gosh
I've answered this five times they they
have not had it answered five times so
it's you know it's definitely a the
dynamic there is one to to be aware of I
think I think it's a good reminder for
whatever role you're in when people keep
asking you the same question question it
might be or maybe there's a reason yeah
right exactly
exactly um okay I know this time goes by
super quickly so I'm gonna try and Rapid
Fire through a few questions but Ashley
I see you just asked one in the chat
want to jump
in oh yeah sorry ready for jumping in
but no
worries Julia love your work um I was
wondering I was looking into your um
learner type models um um from the
learner package and I I've really um
taken a liky in to some of the packages
that were created especially this one
but I know it probably hasn't been
updated in you know two years so I was
wondering if there's plans to if you had
plans to revisit
it I so that if you look at who
contributed to that you'll see that a
lot of work happened during one summer
and it was because we had a um an intern
an intern who came in and like really
worked on that and I think the work I am
really proud of the work that we did
there and I think I mean if you are
running into a problem like where
something isn't working with current
versions please do report a um please do
report a uh like a GitHub issue a bug
somewhere because we want to make sure
that continues to work I think I think
like the those interactive learn our you
know kind of things can be so effective
and actually I remember back to when I
started um learning r i r was not my
first programming language like I came
from like a like a lower like a C
background like a lower so I had like
computational background but I was like
okay I want to learn this R thing seems
pretty cool I actually the the thing
that I loved the most was actually swirl
which which has um I don't even know if
it's still maintained or not but like
this is like eight 10 years ago and my
love what I loved about it is you were
actually in the IDE interactively doing
stuff and learner has that same feel
right like that same kind of feel and is
such an effective way because really
really really like we learn by doing we
learn by like just doing doing doing
doing so it's so it's so effective so
I'm very proud of it um we so I would
say that on the um on the Tidy models
team
specifically um what has what has uh
been a focus I would say lately is more
the Tidy models website so if you for
example like if you go to the tides
models website and go over to learn um
you're you'll see there's there's quite
a lot of stuff there and so there's been
more emphasis on um on on things that
are that are more like content you read
content you read versus content that you
interact with partly because the barrier
is so low you know like so the Tidy
models this tidy mods.org was Rec moved
over to being a Cordo site it was
originally actually technically a Blog
down site it wasn't a Blog but it was
technically a Blog down site and now
it's a Cordo um site and so the so that
makes the barrier so low to like making
a new article it's so like
straightforward to do that so I would
say there are there are not concrete
current plans to add more things to
learn tidy models which is the learn our
thing but um I think it's an interesting
question to to examine right like what
is what are the really effective ways
for people to um to learn the other
thing that we have done um that um oh
wait no never mind never mind yes so
yeah the um I would say that that's I'm
glad you brought that up because I don't
think we have currently current plans to
add more um but I think it's an
interesting question and quick question
and I only asked that one because I I
love the learner package I'm actually
creating my own little course us us
learner um for to help introduce people
to R in my field industrial
organizational psychology and I actually
reached out to some people at um posit
and I was wondering because right now it
still runs on only on our markdown and I
think that it would maybe you know I
don't know if anyone's looking into
moving it into posit it seems like it's
still main so not posit um quto quto
yeah um yeah it seems like it's still
being maintained but I'm not sure if
there was any plans just because I you
know there's a couple other people I
know that made learner courses and it's
so you know it helps to bridge that Gap
Al you know also and something I
encourage new Learners to do is to learn
in our studio yeah which is also why I
love swirl and that also helps the
barrier as well so that'd be curious
yeah yeah I am not super connected to
that team so I don't have a concrete
answer um uh yeah I don't know I don't
know how much how possible it would be
to do that in CTO but that's a really
interesting idea as well I mean it's a
great Point actually I can connect with
you on LinkedIn and maybe try and find
the right person internally to yeah
share that feedback with too yeah that
would be great thank you so much um
Javier I see you had a question a little
bit earlier I'm seeing a lot of love on
that question do you want to jump in
here thanks Rachel um yeah Julia I I
joined late but always a fan of uh your
work so I just one of the questions I
had was we like I work with a lot of
really talented kind of diverse data
scientists or ML and we're writing
internal packages all the time some of
them in my opinion would be incredible
if we could over you know open source
but there's a sort of you know concern
that we work with member data that
there's Hippa and Phi and pii none of it
really making its way to packages but
there is still that concern that somehow
there could be leakage or you know but
in in general I've struggled trying to
convince kind of the topmost level folks
to allow us to um you know open source
some packages now I didn't know if you
had any recommendations there yeah that
is that is so interesting and like that
is such an interesting question because
people like sometimes Le lead ERS ship
in a company like the risk the risk
feels too big compared to whatever like
they're like a why do you want to do
that you know so I think the way so
sometimes you work at orgs that really
value open source like value
contributing to open source you know
like so my most immediate place I worked
before here was stack Overflow and stack
Overflow um uh had an ecos like an ethos
of like it's normal to contribute to
open source and because actually so and
before even data scientists got there
they already had that ethos like there
were it was it's largely like a net C
kind of shop and like some of the like
like some of the most widely used um
like logging libraries some of these
things were made by stack Overflow devs
and it was open source and so they
already had kind of this ethos and so
when I showed up and I'm like oh um
we're going to do this and this
and I um want like I want to open-
Source this piece and they're like yep
sure you know so that's a kind of
situation where people already have Buy
in but if you work in like health care
or you work in finance or you work in
something that has like higher um higher
constraints around um uh like like data
privacy than like a tech company where
everything is kind of public anyway it's
like all on the you know it's sa
overflow it's like there's there is user
data that you don't want linked but so
much of it is p like there's a public
kind of ethos it was like different if
you don't work in that I think um I
think the thing to do is to like clearly
lay out why they should do it at all and
I think I think there's a there's like
why should they let you like let you
spend time on that and I think one is um
uh one is that it can like depending you
know and in this market maybe this is
not so compelling but like for
recruiting like if you are in an org and
you're like we maybe we work in like a
field that's viewed as a little stuffy
or boring but you're like no we can show
people that we um the kind of work we do
by having uh an open-source library or
two and you can say like it can be used
as a recruiting tool to show people the
kind of tools they'll be using with the
kind of like way so so there's like
recruiting there is um uh I like I know
Pharma has just gone through like a big
kind of like is it like if we all band
together and make these tools we can we
can use them then in our compliance like
like how we need to report kinds of
things that's exactly what I would love
to do too like sort of like uh you know
get all the brains together in the
healthcare insurance space for the
greater good yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
think I think like
the the that like that there has to be a
uh like a
compelling case made and then also like
how like how are you going to make sure
like like what like how what processes
are going to be in place so that their
their reasonable concerns about data
privacy are addressed you know like so I
think I it's definitely tougher when you
are in when you are in a um industry
that has high compliance standards um uh
but I do think the Pharma example is a
one of like why like how it can work out
how it can work out to make things
better actually overall for everyone I
mean those people are all like
competitors I'm always so amazed I'm
always so amazed at what they how they
collaborate it's pretty
cool me too shout out to RN Pharma for
that's been happening this this week too
the conference um Julie do you have time
for one more question meeting I do I
don't okay oh you can stay and hang out
forever a little bit
yeah um Alan I realized I had missed a
question you asked from a bit earlier if
you're still on do you want to jump
in uh yeah I am um I I gotta run also it
so I'll drop in my question and then and
then I'll I'll listen and then I'll run
thanks thanks Julie and everybody um I'm
really curious Julia if there are
conscientious decisions about things
that don't fit in tidy models either
because of like statistical weirdness or
Niche or software engineering complexity
curious about the kinds of
decision-making about things that that
just don't belong and and and how you
sort of put those fences up around the
framework yes so there for sure are and
I so here's where I will
admit that um I actually don't have a
super strong statistical background like
I like my background is physics and
astronomy I'm not a statistician like a
lot of you I literally have never Tak
statistics course and through my whole
my whole education so some of this but
absolutely uh so I'm fairly self-taught
when it comes to these kinds of things
so some of these things that I'm about
to say um I would say were not
necessarily my call um but we're calls
that I'm like ah makes sense yes totally
totally we're going to do this um I like
there's a a specific example in one of
the Tidy models package that is called
um that is called the uh that is called
R sample and it is the package for for
resampling for resampling data and the
um uh there is a there is a uh let me
see if I can find it really quick
there's a um there's a certain
resampling method there's certainly
something you can do but um it actually
has pretty bad bad characteristics it
has pretty bad um uh when when it comes
to um uh deciding like how it is that
you going to do um resampling for a
model or something like that it does not
um have good characteristics it's it's
uh I think it's it's leave one out leave
one out cross validation and it um uh
they're they're pretty bad and so we
actually do have um uh guard rails set
up in some of the other tidy models
packages that if you have a leave one
out cross validation um set it won't let
you tune with it it like won't let you
tune with it because it's like pretty
much always a bad idea another example
is like um uh when you're doing machine
learning or modeling like um often what
you'll see in a like you'll see like um
let's walk through how to do this and
then we're going to predict using the
training set and then we're gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna um compute
some kind of um measure some kind of um
um metric using the training sets and
that is almost certainly going to cause
um uh like that that's going to be an
overly optimistic result and so it's
actually kind of hard to do that in tidy
models like and then we still we get
requests being like I need to I want the
metrics on the training set but that um
uh so definitely there are these there
are these um uh guard rails and and tidy
models was built with many of these
guard rails in mind to try to like keep
help you to do the right thing and make
it hard to do the wrong thing I think it
happens less when it comes to software
uh like like oh we can't do that like
that is like pretty much we are always
willing to try to do something if we
think it's a good idea so I think it
happens much more on the statistical
side than the um than than the actual
like software side because with with
enough creativity and energy it's pretty
much it's pretty much possible to do
anything
that's a great question though awesome
yeah the same I like the same thing
applies like in vver like um we we have
there's there's quite a lot of guard
rails in there think thing happens even
in like the Tidy verse you know like it
tries to keep you from doing something
that we almost certainly is a bad idea
you
know awesome thank you making it hard to
do the wrong thing is such a great
framework and such a good way to to put
it um thank you this has been great I I
got to run bye everybody thank you thank
you so much I know we're bit over here
but thank you so much Julia for for
joining us today and sharing your
experience and everything that you do
for the community as well so nice to see
so many of you here today too yeah thank
you all so every much for coming and
thank you for having me absolutely have
a great rest of day everybody
bye